JONATHAN BERI: Hi, I'm Jonathan
Beri and I'm on the
developer relations
team for Google+.
Today I'm going to introduce
you to the
Google+ Hangouts API.
Hangouts let you set up a one
click video conversation with
friends, family, coworkers
and interesting people
from around the world.
You can catch up with your
fantasy football teammates,
get face to face feedback on
your vocal solo, meet other
model train lovers, or
collaborate with remote
colleagues on a shared document
in real time.
All over a high quality,
easy to use video chat.
If Hangouts are a room where you
can bring people together,
Hangout Apps are the kitchen
table you're all sitting at.
A shared space for board games,
sketchbooks, sewing
machines, or calendars.
They're the feature that
spark the conversation.
The Google+ Hangouts API
allows you to develop
collaborative Apps that run
inside of Google+ Handout.
Hangout Apps are normal web apps
that can take advantage
of rich, real time
functionality in
the Hangouts API.
Apps have the ability to control
aspects of the user
interface, synchronize data
between people, and respond to
events in the Hangout.
With Hangouts it's better to
show you then to tell you, so
I'll fire up a Hangout and
invite a few of my friends
from the Hangouts page.
I'll log in to Hangout and
invite my friends from
developer relations,
Wolf and Jenny.
Hey Jenny.
Hey Wolf.
JENNY: Hi Wolf.
WOLF: Hey Jenny.
JONATHAN BERI: We have a
team offsite coming up.
Why don't we use a Hangout
App to plan out our trip?
WOLF: Sounds good.
JENNY: Sounds like
a great idea.
JONATHAN BERI: I'll
pull up one of
the Apps we've developed.
So what you're seeing here is
a Hangout App running inside
of a Hangout.
This is a demo using the Google
Earth plug-in and I'm
going to go fly around the
world, pick some cool places
to go to, and we're going
to collaborate
on that list together.
So I'm thinking Malpais,
Costa Rica.
WOLF: I hear exciting things
are happening in Mountain
View, California.
JONATHAN BERI: See what
just happened there?
Wolf picked Mountain View,
California, on his map and it
showed up on my screen using
the data channel API.
So if I tag it, he'll see
Malpais on his map.
And as Jenny's looking
for a cool place,
that'll show up as well.
Tagged by Jenny, nice.
It's a very simple API that
allows you to synchronize any
type of information
across the App.
But we can do more than just
locations on a map.
We can actually follow each
other using that same API.
So I'm going to click on Wolf
and see what he sees.
WOLF: Well, I'm thinking we
should take our offsite to
McMurdo Station in Antarctica.
It's pretty cool.
We can look around here.
Pull back.
JONATHAN BERI: Neat.
So we're using the same API that
we used to synchronize
the locations.
We can do more than just sync
data across the Apps.
We can do fun things like
moustaches and overlays.
I'll show you with
the costume App.
Now here are a bunch
of costumes that
I can try out virtually.
Let's say, top hat.
Oh yeah, looks pretty good.
What we're actually doing here
is using our overlay API.
With the overlay API I can pick
a resource, create it
inside the plug-in, and attach
it to any parts of our face.
And then that overlay
tracks along.
Looking stylish, Jenny.
Wolf, I think you've got to get
a little bit smaller on
that mustache.
WOLF: No, I think--
I've had almost any size
mustache here and I'm not
sure, I'm thinking this kind.
JONATHAN BERI: Wolf's using
the ability to scale and
offset his mustache using
the API as well.
Now, because this is an API we
can use great features of
HTML5 to do more than
just images.
For example, we can actually
draw our costume.
So switch over to the drawing
canvas, pick a cursor, I think
I'm going to make a
crown for myself.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a good crown.
How do I look guys?
WOLF: You look like
a king or somebody
wearing a sponge cake.
JONATHAN BERI: Wolf, you
look way better.
Glasses on glasses.
WOLF: I look this good all the
time even without overlays.
There you go, Jenny.
JONATHAN BERI: So now you have
goggles and glasses.
JENNY: Exactly, multi-goggle.
JONATHAN BERI: Let's now
demonstrate how you can add
animations into your App.
Switch over to the animate
mode, guys.
The API also includes the
ability to access parts of the
hardware, such as
the mic volume.
So I like PBR, I'm going to
click the PBR option.
Now I've got a cool fedora with
my hipster character.
WOLF: I've always wanted to be
a bear, so now I'm a bear.
JONATHAN BERI: Nice.
JENNY: And I had techno
colored hair
before, it was cool.
So, oh perfect.
Blue hair.
WOLF: There you go.
JONATHAN BERI: We can all
talk in sync right?
WOLF: Yes.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
JENNY: Can indeed.
JONATHAN BERI: We've also added
the ability for you to
respond to facial motion within
your application.
Let me share a cool demo.
So in this demo I've loaded up
a WebGL of a giant funny head
and it's actually responding
to my facial movement.
Literally your face can
become a controller.
I can zoom in, I can zoom out.
Left, right, up, down.
And for kicks we've added the
ability to track your mouth
movement using your volume.
Pretty neat, huh?
It's just that easy.
You can find all the details
that you need, including
sample code, tutorials, and
reference documentation, on
the Google+ Developer
site today.
This means you can get
started right now.
Thanks for watching.